[Music]
this week we're exploring whether
america is ready for a coronavirus
vaccine
in a special three-part series road to a
vaccine
two major clinical trials are resuming
in the u.s
after being paused over safety concerns
estimates show the earliest time for an
approved vaccine
could be the end of november a recent
poll
showed a sharp decrease in the number of
americans who would get a vaccine
right away arsene senior medical
correspondent dr tara narulis spoke
with a wide-ranging group about its
thoughts on a vaccine tara good morning
good morning anthony we spoke to a large
panel and the group really fell
on different sides of the issue alyssa
kogut is diabetic
and says she will definitely get a
vaccine new dad chad st
claire is adamant he will not lisey
marshall
a neuroscience college student says she
trusts the science but will wait a few
months to get a vaccine
sienna marie sesma is still unsure due
to concerns about potential side effects
adam davis lives in hard-hit california
and is hesitant but open to it we also
spoke to dr
catherine stevenson who participated in
the early development of the johnson and
johnson covet 19 vaccine candidate
as an and is an investigator in trials
of other covit 19 vaccine candidates
on a scale of one to ten give me your
confidence level in a vaccine
six seven and a half i would say seven
or an eight
i'm gonna say one or two i'm gonna say
eight
is there anything that would move you
along that confidence scale
one way or another if somehow after
however many months
the participants of the preliminary
vaccine research
start to come out with any side effects
that would definitely change my mind
how many of you are in general just
concerned
about the idea of taking a new vaccine
i feel that though the fda
has done the majority of good things
they have also taken
products off the market that they
approved at one point we just don't know
enough about the
vaccine yet i'm young i'm healthy
i exercise and i'm low risk yeah
that's that's my feeling also is that we
don't know much about the vaccine
or the long-term short-term or long-term
effects it sounds like most of you are
more concerned with the potential risks
or side effects
than anything else yeah that's the
opposite for me
that's the opposite for you yes because
i know this virus and i know what it can
do to you
i have diabetes and my daughter has
asthma she's only seven
so i would definitely take it to protect
me and my kids
i'm on the other side i don't want to
panic i know a lot of people who have
had it
and have recovered nicely
as well as our leader of our country i
know that they're coming across this
really quickly
so for me if i see people actually
taking it and working i'd be more
inclined to do it
dr stevenson how do you reassure people
who are being asked to take a novel
vaccine that there may not be an adverse
event
years down the road well the first thing
i would say is that it's
very unusual for a vaccine to have a
long-term side effect
most of the side effects associated with
vaccines
have to do with upfront so something
like an allergic reaction
and that's that's true for all vaccines
do any of you
feel that political pressure has played
a role or could play a role
in a vaccine being prematurely approved
no i don't think trump has any control
over making the vaccine
or rushing the vaccine i think it has a
little bit to do with it
especially with what's going on and you
can tell where
there is some pushing on both sides i
would agree i feel like unfortunately
this year
a scary pandemic has been um politicized
more than it would have been probably if
it weren't um an election year
i think the politics side is giving um
sometimes a lot of false hope that it's
going to happen faster
than it really is so i think that it's
creating confusion a lot of people hear
operation warp speed they hear we've
produced a vaccine
in seven or eight months when normally
it takes you know 10 years
typically an academic vaccine research
researcher would have to like apply for
a lot of
grants and start begging for money to do
more research
but now this was like everybody knew
that this was something we had to do and
there was a lot of funding then
how do you make a partnership with a
pharmaceutical company usually that
takes a year
at least to negotiate some sort of
collaboration
that was instant it sounds like what
you're saying is that
we've really trimmed out the fat so to
speak and
cut out points along the way
that were not necessary but really were
delays
that we could easily get rid of without
compromising
the research exactly exactly i have a
few questions though
because we know about the flu vaccine
and is that 100
affected and that is the chronovirus is
going to be 100
be 100 infected you may have a vaccine
that's maybe 60 70 percent effective
prevents a lot of deaths
not everyone but significantly uh
slows down transmission of the virus
which benefits everyone
so if you have a hundred percent of
people take the vaccine
and it's only 50 effective um you're
gonna do a lot better
than if the vaccine is 100 effective but
only a few people taken
such interesting numbers tara how can
americans be made to feel confident
that an approved vaccine is safe
anthony that really is top of mind for
so many americans that issue of safety
and you
heard it in the panel but this is where
we need to listen to the words of dr
stevenson and other experts who really
have said that those
adverse effects those side effects
typically occur 99
of the time in those first weeks to
first few months and that it is rare to
have longer term
adverse effects in fact the fda has said
it will not approve a vaccine until they
have
two months of safety data all of that
being said health experts also say
we need a robust data system put in
place to monitor
for any rare or unusual long-term
adverse effects
all right tara thank